[Musica]
[Applauso]
Il tema principale di questa giornata e
del mio speech è il tempo tema così
delicato che ho ben 12 minuti per
parlarne un po'
paradossale ma anche intrigante Come
fare a parlare di un argomento così
delicato e al contempo collegarlo a
degli aspetti della propria sfera
personale e lavorativa in così poco
tempo e in più devo anche lasciare
qualcosa al pubblico una follia però dai
proviamoci ogni giorno parlo di inglese
dei suoi accenti e della sua
meravigliosa lingua ma oggi
no oggi voglio parlarvi di una domanda
che mi viene fatta spesso dai miei
alunni che seppur in relazione
all'inglese si collega benissimo ai
diversi meandri della nostra
quotidianità voglio parlarvi di ordine
di Chaos di
Adventure voglio parlarvi di verità una
mia verità che magari molti di voi
condividono o non
[Musica]
condividono Ma che non hanno mai avuto
la possibilità di
articolare la domanda in questione è
Quanto tempo ci vuole i miei alunni mi
fanno questa domanda in relazione
all'inglese chiedendomi Quanto tempo ci
vuole per imparare questa lingua ma
indipendentemente dall'obiettivo che si
cerca di raggiungere la domanda sembra
rimanere
invariata Quanto tempo ci vuole per
mettersi in forma Quanto tempo ci vuole
per imparare uno strumento musicale
Quanto tempo ci vuole per arrivare a
destinazione da queste domande si vince
che l'omo è fondamentalmente
ossessionato dal controllo del quando da
quando otterrà un determinato risultato
deve essere entro quest'anno entro
l'anno prossimo entro un certo
orario questo Signori si chiama
Order l'organizzazione del tempo in
blocchi l'ordine è l'unica cosa che ci
permette di sfuggire alle grinfie delle
forze esterne che governano il mondo
come l'imprevedibilità e la sfortuna
l'ordine è ricevere lo stipendio in
tempo
l'ordine è trovare un pasto caldo
all'ora di pranzo l'ordine è avere i
nostri genitori che ci aspettano
puntuali Al termine delle
lezione in sostanza l'ordine è la nostra
zona di comfort è quella porzione di
mondo che siamo riusciti a privatizzare
a fare nostra e che di conseguenza
possiamo nel limite del possibile
prevedere tutto ciò che sta al di fuori
di questi blocchi di tempo tutto ciò che
sta al di fuori della nostra zona di
comfort di controllo tutto ciò che non
possiamo fondamentalmente prevedere
quello si chiama chaos e ne siamo
terrorizzati questa paura dell'ignoto
dello sconosciuto ha però generato una
sorta di misconception una concezione
erronea nell'immaginario collettivo
dell'uomo Ovvero che se le azioni che
compiamo nel breve termine non ci danno
un risultato tangibile nell'immediatezza
Allora non valgono niente mentre se
compiamo delle azioni a breve termine
che ci danno effettivamente un risultato
tangibile nell'immediatezza Allora
valgono
qualcosa ma la verità che ci cela dietro
questa sorta di horror vacui in cui
siamo intrappolati è che sono proprio le
cose che ci mettono tanto tempo per
manifestarsi ad avere un grande valore
perché è proprio
l'effort la fatica appunto la quantità
di tempo che impieghiamo per ottenerli a
conferire loro un
valore
molti smettono di andare in palestra
perché non vedono risultati dopo qualche
sessione di
allenamento molti smettono di imparare
uno strumento musicale perché non sanno
suonare Le quattro stagioni di Vivaldi e
neanche sanno leggere le note sul
pentagramma molti smettono di parlare
inglese perché dopo qualche sessione di
lezione non sanno
dialogare Ma se avere un fisico
statuario fosse facile allora tutti lo
avrebbero e non sarebbe speciale
e se imparare ing che la lingua franca A
livello mondiale e avere la possibilità
di comunicare con tutti illimitatamente
fosse una cosa da poco e tutti
imparassimo inglese facilmente Allora
perderebbe il suo valore e quindi che si
fa Si va all'avventura
Adventure una cosa che sicuramente molti
di voi hanno contemplato come fa the wer
the Sea of Fog Ma che non si deve
fermare alla mera riflessione passare
all'azione perché
l'avventura ovvero l'addendo l'ignoto
dentro il caos è l'unica cosa che ci
permette di sfuggire da quella apparente
stabilità che ci tiene saldi al suolo
senza darci la possibilità di
muoverci senza darci la possibilità di
volare abbracciate l'adventure
come ha fatto Lisse che nonostante
imprevisti intemperie mostri continuato
la sua strada verso itaka non sapendo se
e quando ci sarebbe arrivato come ho
fatto io che ai tempi del covid ho
iniziato a pubblicare video Random sui
social in un ambiente che era già Saturo
prima di
cominciare ogni giorno era una fatica
costante impiegavo ore e ore sui video
ero lento a pubblicarli e i risultati
che venivano Erano veramente bassi poche
engagement poche views un ambiente Iper
competitivo già pieno di persone è che
facevano questa cosa insegnavano
inglese quindi Perché continuare è una
perdita di
tempo non emerger
mai ecco tutte le vocine che abitavano
la mia testa e che crearono una sorta di
circolo vizioso caratterizzato da
incertezza invidia
paura Ma come disse Jordan
Peterson
Se osservi l'abisso abbastanza a lungo
alla fine vedi la luce non il
buio e io sapevo che il mio modo di fare
inglese era diverso dagli altri sapevo
che con l'arte della consapevolezza
della perseveranza sarei riuscito a
destreggiarmi anche in un ambiente così
per
competitivo sapevo che la stessa arte mi
avrebbe permesso di realizzare alcuni
sogni del cassetto Come essere qui in
questo perchio rosso e parlare di fronte
a voi a un
tedx nonostante non vedessi la
manifestazione tangibile del mio sogno
ho continuato ad andare
avanti perché Contro quelle vocine
maligne che navigavano all'interno della
mia mente ce n'era un'altra che si
opponeva e diceva you on the right track
sei sulla giusta
strada andare all'avventura è stato
personalmente la scelta
più bella della mia vita sapete
perché
manif
perché se la tua voglia di fare supera
la tua stessa mania di controllo umano
Allora sì che puoi puntare a qualcosa di
valore e se il non vedere la tua meta o
la manifestazione tangibile del tuo
sogno Comunque non ti permette di
fermarti allora sì che puoi puntare alla
grandezza Quindi la prossima volta che
qualcuno vi chiede quanto tempo ci vuole
voi per
favore per
favore
rispondete
over Time letteralmente nel
tempo siate gli eroi del racconto della
vostra vita perché significa che avrete
abbracciato l'adventure avrete
abbandonato il porto sicuro dove
attracca la vostra zona di comfort e
avrete imparato ad amare la
destinazione Thank
you
off I
go